Australia's great Victoria desert
s of sand
Hill size of California
Ed kavaner is heading deep into this
vast Wilderness drawn by something weird
revealed from space
I've lived in Australia my whole life
and never seen anything quite like this
before
an image taken over the region on April
8 2021.
has captured this pattern in the Red
Sands below
out in the middle of nowhere is this
giant carving on the earth looks like
kind of wedges of a pizza
it's very strange middle of it has been
cleared in a way that it forms almost
the bullseye
symbol covers an area equivalent to 600
football fields and has spokes up to
1400 feet in length
with Precision which can only mean that
some sort of government or military
operation has taken place here
[Music]
what's more the remains of an identical
shape sit nearby
great effort appears to have been made
to erase evidence of it
as a journalist when I see something
clandestine in my own backyard I feel
compelled to go and investigate it
officially there are no towns near the
site
but evidence on the ground suggests
otherwise
wow this is insane I mean this
completely deserted Ghost Town
must be a coincidence
just 15 miles from the mystery symbols
sits this Ghost Town
dozens of its buildings have been raised
to the ground this clearly would have
been a very sizable Community here looks
like it's been abandoned for decades
[Applause]
whatever forced this town to flee it
appears to have happened almost
overnight
[Music]
chairs and Equipment are left exactly in
place as they would have been decades
ago
everyone's just got up and left
in each room cabinet finds evidence of
government activity
this vehicle was completely out of place
here
it's clearly been modified for some
purpose
got a completely enclosed cabin to
separate this part of the vehicle from
those who are driving it
the vehicle appears to be designed to
contain something extremely hazardous
Bud Light images of another ghost town
in Australia could offer a clue
what you do know is that a town in
Australia did have to evacuate because
of a toxic asbestos mine
could this have been the same case in
the town we're looking at here
between the 1940s and the 1960s miners
in the town of Whitney excavate around
000 tons of blue asbestos from the
desert
over the years 2 000 people die from
unwittingly inhaling the cancerous
fibers before the government shuts down
the mine and wipes the town off the map
it's actually the largest contaminated
site in the entire southern hemisphere
that's big
the nightmare scenario is that the ghost
town and the shapes in the image may be
evidence of another equally deadly
disaster on Australian soil
one that authorities are trying to cover
up
something bad has happened to you to
make people abandon this town and I'm
certain it's got something to do with
those Wagon Wheel shapes I've seen in
the desert
the indigenous people here call this
area the big evil
and the journalist soon learns why
closer I get to the Wagon Wheel shapes
the vegetation is Getting Thinner and
thinner
it's almost as if some sort of event has
taken place here that is just wiped all
of the life off the face of the Earth
arriving at the coordinates Kavanaugh
discovers a vast flat area
first thing I've noticed is these
strange hooks that are embedded into
this concrete slab
I'm not sure at all what these would be
pinning to the ground but it certainly
adds to the mystery here
nearby Kavanagh finds more objects not
visible in the satellite image
[Music]
rocket launching devices are incredibly
old and brittle they'll rusted out
[Music]
the rocket launchers are weird enough
but what really intrigues kavener is
what surrounds them
[Applause]
there's this field of Green Glass it
almost looks like a green jade all
across the ground out here
[Music]
of desert around the mystery shapes
Shimmer with the deformed beads of glass
Cavender believes this is trinitite a
substance formed when sand is subjected
to temperatures in excess of 3000
degrees Fahrenheit
this suggests to me that this has to
have been made from a nuclear weapons
test
I must say I'm completely speechless
discovering this year
what's concerning is that there are only
nine countries with known nuclear
weapons capabilities
and Australia isn't one of them
the idea is just unfathomable but
there's just no other explanation and
it's just completely shocking
hi it's uh it's Edward Kavanagh
Cavender turns to his newspaper contacts
to track down someone who might be able
to shed some light
all right thanks
[Music]
Jeremy labois is a member of the
marilinga jarajar a council of local
Aboriginal peoples
hi Jeremy
he confirms that 60 years ago Atomic
Testing did take place in this desert
but not ones conducted by the Australian
government where we are today is where
the British tested seven atomic bombs
that were bigger than what they dropped
on Japan
in 1952 the British become the world's
third nuclear power and are desperate to
play catch-up with the US and Soviet
Union
to do that the small densely populated
Nation needs to persuade another country
to host their nuclear tests the British
government looked for testing sites in
the U.S and Canada but were turned down
and then Britain knocks on the door of
Australia part of the old Empire and the
Aussies go you know what yeah we'll have
your nukes let's blow up some nukes in
our deserts
in exchange for sharing nuclear secrets
the Australian government grants the
British vast swaths of land for their
tests
but it's land that belongs to LA boys
and his people
Jeremy how much notice were the
traditional owners of this land given
about the nuclear tests absolutely
nothing not one of them ever ever sat
down with the traditional owners and
asked them for permission and not one of
them